javon robbins reporting from france well
there's wildfires in europe
uh there are fires in kent this is a
huge blaze a grass fire in kent near
dartford as you can see
a lot of grass ablaze and it is very
close to
houses in fact
it's just encroaching on those houses
there and you can see sheds and
outbuildings and some cars
there some of the outbuildings it seems
are ablaze i'm just seeing this at the
same time as you are this is the latest
we have um from the sky helicopter
that's taken to the skies above this in
kent as i said it's near dartford right
near those houses it's understood that
the blaze uh started in the grassy area
to the right of the picture and the wind
has blown it
towards that row of houses that is a
very worrying picture for residents
there that is dartford in kent um
temperatures there exceeding 40 degrees
celsius uh today's record-breaking
temperatures as we said the record
broken at heathrow
40.2 degrees celsius um the sky
helicopter just pulling out there
there's a lot of smoke
and as you can appreciate from such dry
grass
a number of fires have been breaking out
across the uk because of the tinder
box conditions are caused by these
record-breaking temperatures there was a
fire in up minster
in essex
earlier on again grassland fire engines
called there to put that out and but
these are pictures we are receiving
from near dartford in
kent a lot of people on social media
on roads nearby taking photographs of
the smoke obviously that's going to blow
in quite
a large direction
just looking at these pictures here as
you can see you can see three four fire
engines on the scene five in fact three
four five um as many as nine being
reported by local media in attendance
it's going to be
vital that they get that fire under
control as you can see from the pictures
these latest pictures they are so close